in recent years the fight against global
terrorism has shifted increasingly to
the sahel region of africa
in mauritania authorities are tapping a
traditional mode of transportation as
part of their anti-terrorism efforts
with help from the european union
they've resurrected a hundred-year-old
nomadic police force known as the camel
corps
this is the latest approach in the fight
against jihadist terrorists in
mauritania a traditional solution to a
modern
problem the mahari national guard are a
police unit recruited from local nomads
their camels are their most important
tool
they're the best way to get around the
vast border region between mauritania
and mali
jihadist groups linked to al-qaeda have
gained ground nearby and authorities
fighting them need the kind of
intelligence that only locals can offer
for example if we see a nomad buying
large quantities of fuel we know that's
not normal
their work is not without danger
while the men cook lieutenant colonel
city lebzarr secures the camp
we unfair a circle
each group has a century and we from the
command are in the center
the mahari police travels through the
desert for months at a time
they don't
as well and communicate that to the
central government in newark
the camel corps are partly funded by
money from the european union
it's an international attempt to improve
security here and in the larger region
known as the sahel
it's counter-terrorism that starts at a
local level
units gather
intelligence they spot the threats and
then anti-terrorism units get involved
and take care of those threats
their job is to also deepen trust with
people people they know from their own
communities they help them by providing
health care
this woman says she has vertigo nausea
and general fatigue that's why i gave
her some albendazole because she could
have a parasite
this approach combining local knowledge
with traditional connections and
offering help as well as asking for
information it's proving
popular a few hundred new mahari police
are already operational
and authorities say they plan to recruit
200 more
you